I think that on campuses buildings teach
I think they teach the students
subliminally about the value of place
and architecture and craft and this
building would be a great representation
of that
building like this is a sensory building
the wood has its own Aroma and color and
richness it has light it has its own
sound and it already has its own
mythology
it has many stories to tell
it would be impossible to come in this
building spend time here and not
remember it
building is a very iconic building
where it's situated close to the edge of
campus with its tower on the New Haven
Skyline it claims itself as a
destination
the humanities are about Research In
Balance with collaboration and in
balance with engagement with communities
of thinkers and enthusiasts
the concept here was of a unified
Humanities environment
it would have been very difficult to
casually bump into somebody from another
department in the building the way it
was it wasn't a building that spoke to
collaboration and commonality these
departments are scattered some of them
were here but French and Italian and
Spanish was over on Wall Street above
the pizza place then if you wanted to go
to complift you had to go to 451 College
German was across the street you can't
build something whole when everything is
fragmented you have to be able to bring
the fragments together we're very well
known for being a place of the
humanities a place that has a singular
leadership role in the humanities not
only in the United States but also
around the world bringing them together
into a single location is really an
opportunity to draw together in a
physical way the commitment we have
always had in a spiritual way the idea
of creating common ground in a building
that had been rather cellular so that
there was a flow in the building was one
of the challenges this is an incredibly
complex process there's a lot of
choreography between understanding the
end user's desires working with the
architect with design aspirations
working with a construction manager for
constructability and putting that all
together
renovating a building is a lot more
challenging than building a new building
for me one of the most exciting things
was thinking how we could make it better
[Music]
there was always a desire to preserve
the architecture of this building it's
such an iconic building James gavel
Rogers did many of the buildings on
campus and there's an expectation of
ornamentation and detail that people
expect when they come into Yale
buildings
the idea of a larger footprint became
very appealing because it could offer us
instructional spans to support the big
collaborative and instructional spaces
without having to tear apart a valued
historic building we put in 12 000
square feet of underground space that
never existed before and as a
state-of-the-art lecture hall and film
screening room down there we have a
courtyard it's really a roof now for
another building the fact that we had to
construct below the water table and
underpin the foundations for the entire
perimeter of the courtyard including a
15-story tower we had to dig down 30
feet dug out 30 000 cubic yards of soil
those are just mind-boggling exercises
in and of themselves
foreign
the entry sequence into this building is
very Grand you have these beautiful
brick arches that welcome you right away
you can go left or right and be in a
light filled hallway now that is adorned
with offices and classroom space
building brings together 15
Apartments
programs near Eastern languages and
civilizations sits on the floor with
directed studies film and media studies
sits adjacent to our department of
Italian language and literature history
is now co-located with units that study
the literary traditions in each of the
regions of the world I can work with
professors and hear the lectures that
they bring in work for grad students
we took many existing corridors and we
actually widened them
we created spaces where people could sit
down have a cup of coffee see some
people
these are connective spaces and they're
intended to be used in a very fluid way
now they have lots of small little rooms
or conferences that we can immediately
just grab another professor move into a
room and talk and widen out the
conversation
you have an access to the tower which in
itself has a beautiful Lobby Swenson
Tower will be home to graduate students
from across a range of departments
the new stair that connects the entrance
foyer to the lowest two levels required
complete structural rethink of that part
of the building it's designed to invite
people when I walked to the building now
it's so easy to imagine how a great
lecture could be given in the lower
level lecture hall and you walk out with
someone that you're sitting next to and
have a conversation in the beautiful
reception space right outside that
lecture hall maybe decide there that
it'd be great to continue that
conversation in your offices which are
only two floors away
I think we always strive to bring people
together in ways that they don't expect
and this project specifically will do
that we're going to have a lot more
interaction among the faculty and
hopefully for the students they will
develop interests that they didn't plan
to develop along the way
[Music]
now this building is a building that
speaks to not only the need for privacy
and individual research but also the
opportunity for the chance to encounter
the collaboration and bringing people
together
Yale would be the first to admit that it
hadn't seen much updating or Improvement
in many decades
if you look at the plan of the building
it's a complex plan the whole basement
level which is now The Concourse was
loaded with steam piping so we had to be
very creative about how to route
everything behind the beautiful
architecture we've probably never met a
building before that had such resistance
to upgrade in its structural composition
there was also the challenge of making
the building fully ADA Compliant fully
accessible
that is a big deal and to try to do that
in a way that's very sensitive to the
architecture is very challenging as well
in order to restore a lot of the detail
in this building we did rely on really
good craft people many of them local we
replace all the windows
we salvaged 284 panels of art class most
of the Millwork is carefully restored we
had a local vendor restoring all the
iron work all of the historic lighting
was sent out to be refurbished with
energy efficient LED and then there's
quite a lot of new lighting to
supplement that
foreign
this didn't just happen
this was planned monitored
and executed in ways that took time and
care and work
structurals Mechanicals civil lighting
designers landscape architect you know
there was a cast of thousands hundreds
and hundreds of Unique Individuals
worked on this particular project a lot
of our local New Haven residents to add
it up we say it's 630 000 hours went
into the renovation of this building by
a wide variety of people you pull these
things off because you have people who
just never give up and the tenacity is
part of the success story of this
project if there's one thing I'm most
proud of it's how well we worked as a
team foreign
I hope that this building will say
something about optimizing existing
conditions in ways that are Innovative
there's the historic nature of the
building from ground floor up and then
there's a much more modern intervention
from Concourse level down and I hope
it'll say something about making a
building that's available to everybody
who uses it by the way that it's
organized it's James Gala Rogers 2.0 if
you will it's a 21st century building
now I hope the students really
understand the value of the humanities
through this building when you walk into
it you can't help but feel inspired at
what could be possible
that we as a university decided to take
one of our Central iconic campus
buildings to rebuild the space in ways
that encouraged collaboration in the
humanities is a signal to the world that
we are committed to this area of
Excellence
[Music]